- Hi, I'm Dan Quinn, originally from McLean, Virginia,
and I created the video about the tears of wine
that form around the edge of wine glasses.
Most people who drink wine have seen the weird drops
that form around the side of the glass.
Traditionally, they're called "tears" or "legs" of wine.
But, what most people don't realize is that,
if you watch patiently, these drops are
actually moving around.
My favorite part is when I'll be at a party or something,
and someone has a glass of wine
and they're twirling it around and they see the legs of wine
or the tears of wine and they say,
"Oh, Dan. Come explain this to us."
- Students, before lab, I can see them
in the hallways watching my videos.
And then also, during lab, sometimes they'll, like,
have it on their phone and they'll be like,
"Well, what did he do in the video?
Just bring it up on your phone."
- My students think it's super cool.
(laughs)
- The second they heard that I had a video on YouTube,
they were, like, really excited.
The mushy food lands in your stomach,
where gastric acid and chemicals
break down the food even more.
- To be a really good teacher,
you just have to be a really good communicator
and you need to also be able to relate to your students.
- I think that a good teacher is engaged and supportive
and responsible and should treat
his or her students with respect.
- If you put yourself in an ivory tower,
or spew and force wisdom onto the masses,
like, that's not gunna help anybody.
The truth is your students are just as smart as you are,
you just happen to know
a little bit more than them for the moment.
- You know, when you're teaching it,
you know it all very well but when you're teaching it
to someone else, you have to think of what they're thinking
and, when I make the videos, I, sort of, keep in mind
what questions pop into their head first.
If you're telling me that we have a seeing threshold
just like how we having a hearing threshold,
wouldn't that mean that there's light waves?
I think what's really important is that they love it
because, when a teacher loves something
and they teach it to you, you, sort of, love it too.
- Usually, when I create a new video,
it's because I found something that's really exciting
that I wanna talk about to people.
And so, I, kind of, can't not talk about it
and I wanna get it all into one thing
that can be my packaged, you know,
delivery of this idea to the world.
- The thing that excites me the most
about video making is actually YouTube comments.
Because of the nature of the content that I produced,
it didn't really attract a whole lot of trolls.
So, all of the comments were just uniformly constructive
or helpful or they would say, "David, you screwed up here."
But they would say it, like, real politely.
- Other fantastic comments include, "That was tolerable."
and "I did not want to blow my brains out
after watching your video."
Those are from harsher critics.
- Ok, so one of my biggest worries
about putting things on YouTube,
you know, YouTube's notorious for critical comments.
And I don't care about that.
That's much better than no comments, in my mind.
But, I was worried that my mom might, you know,
she's naturally gunna watch videos.
She cares about what her son's doing.
And I don't want her to see people
saying bad things about her son.
No mother wants that.
So, I was a little bit stressed about that
to start 'cuz I don't care.
That's just critical feedback, especially with education.
So, it was a bit of a relief, when, at least, you know,
so far, people are, by and large, very, very nice about it.
- The initial feedback I got from my students
about the videos and providing that has just been amazing.
And I never thought that it would be as well received.
And, of course, I also never thought that
that would lead to being here at Khan Academy.
- And so, I would encourage anyone
who wants to do this, who thinks they have something to say
about history, science, mathematics,
to just go out there and give it to the world.
- I feel like teaching is the best way to learn sometimes.
- Each professor, each teacher,
each tutor has their own style and, I think,
any person can bring out their own style,
from their personality, from the way
they think about things.
That's something that only they can offer
and they can offer it the best.
- I hope my videos show that, you know,
if you break it down into one step after the other,
you can really understand even the most complex phenomenon.